good morning Hank it's Tuesday so listen
I've been helping out with some of your
jobs on account of the chemotherapy and
I kind of can't believe that you do all
of this like it just sort of strains the
imagination that you are the CEO of our
educational Media company complexly and
of dftba.com and the founder of the
awesome socks and coffee clubs and Sun
Basin soap and also that you're the host
of Crash Course scishow Journey to the
micro Cosmos vlogbrothers and a bad
advice podcast as we used to say in
French class back home in Alabama cine
Papo sibla like Hank you often credit me
for coming up with the idea for crash
course which is fair because I did come
up with the idea for crash course I
loved making educational videos on
vlogbrothers but I wanted to do it in a
bigger and better way and I recognize
that we couldn't do that alone but the
thing is having that idea did not get
crash course 15 billion YouTube
subscribers over 1.8 billion views and a
place in many American high schools and
colleges because ideas to borrow a line
from wh odd and make nothing happen or
least they make nothing happen on their
own ideas matter but for things to
actually happen Logistics and systems
have to build up people have to
collaborate there's often even a need
for and I struggle with how hard this
word is for me to say but there's
sometimes a need for
meetings so yeah maybe I came up with
the idea for crash course but I didn't
make it happen and in fact I couldn't
have made it happen not only because I
really dislike a meeting for crash
course to become real and especially for
it to remain real it needed you Hank and
also thousands of other collaborators
who you could welcome into that process
writers editors curriculum Consultants
animators teachers and the thousands of
people who support crash course every
year which allow us to keep making it
free for everyone forever now some of
those people support us by patreon but
many support us via drumroll please the
Crash Course coin which was your idea
idea Hank and usually it would be Hank
talking about the Crash Course coin but
this year you get me Great Value Hank
Green this year's crash course coins
which are available only for the next 11
days were minted in Arkansas from hand
engraved dyes and gosh are they
beautiful this year's engraving was
inspired by this photograph taken by the
jwst if you held a grain of sand at
arm's length that's about how much of
the sky we're seeing here and yet it is
vast teeming with galaxies that were
only just learning how to see and for me
the coin image represents how learning
can illuminate unseen areas of ourselves
and our universe and it also represents
how acquiring and building knowledge can
lead to ever more acquisition and
building of knowledge and I think that's
how breakthroughs in technology and
understanding really happen not with one
brilliant person having one brilliant
idea but with many many people having
ideas and working together like a few
human lifetimes ago we didn't even know
there were galaxies and now we know that
smudge is a Galaxy this year we're
minting four crash course coins one for
three year patrons one a hundred dollar
coin that supports 2 000 crash course
Learners a limited edition 500 coin that
supports 10 000 Learners and an even
more limited edition one thousand dollar
coin that supports twenty thousand crash
course Learners each of these coins is
minted on a different metal and some
come with signed thank you notes but the
main thing is they're all amazing and
Incredibly important to crash course's
ability to fulfill its Mission and I
mean that this is not like some tiny
slice of a massive corporate pie the
patreon and coin campaigns represent the
single largest slice of the annual crash
course budget like this year thanks to
support from the coin we launched crash
courses in Black American history botany
biology and crash course on espanol
among many others I've been The
Reluctant and temporary CEO of this
Enterprise for about 18 days and so I
feel like I can say with some Authority
that this just would not be possible
without support from our viewers so
thank you if you can afford to get a
coin and of course no worries if you
can't
crashcoursecoin.com heck after a couple
weeks of having a small portion of your
jobs I am of course impressed by your
astonishing productivity and your
commitment to bring beautiful and
interesting things into the world but I
do think I've begun to at least Glimpse
how you do it which is that you don't do
it alone or even anywhere close to a
loan you do it with a huge array of
colleagues and collaborators and
together you're able to make something
that none of us would be able to make
alone that's the story of crash course
it's the story of jwst and it's the
story of how almost everything worth
doing gets done together so you can help
us reach more Learners with crash
courses resources crashcoursecoin.com
Hank I will see you today actually
so that'll be nice